elle passe un boucle à la télé
les images de dévastation rabian
n'arrive pas à se les sortir de la tête
cette montréalaise est originaire dadana
l'une des plus grandes villes de Turquie
dans le sud durement frappé par le
séisme
des immeubles à cet endroit comme
ailleurs se sont complètement effondrées
et mes frères ils étaient ensemble mais
ce matin j'ai essayé de les appeler mais
le téléphone ne fonctionne pas
malheureusement
touché par le drame des associations
turques de Montréal lance une campagne
pour recueillir des dons environ 20 000
ressortissants comme Semia habite ici
une communauté solidaire dit-elle
[Musique]
des articles seront amassés au centre
culturel turc et envoyé par avion à
partir de Montréal mercredi yes le
président de l'association turque reçoit
d'ailleurs déjà des appels de ceux qui
veulent faire leurs parts
des manteaux des bottes expliquent-ils
tout ce qui peut servir au sinistré qui
n'en nulle part où aller
oui
Madison
et avec nos partenaires à
l'international ce qu'on peut faire pour
aider
pour aider aussi la Syrie qui compte
elle aussi c'est mort ça passe vite
comme ça Georges installé à Montréal a
toujours de la famille là-bas il a perdu
un ami qu'il considérait comme un frère
de son frère ici il a dit vous avez
perdu ton meilleur ami je dis non
de me concentrer normal quelqu'un n'y
soit pas quand on a la tête ailleurs ici
Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada montré